hello everybody welcome back to finding
paradise so glad you made it
we've been playing for hours oh my god
apparently the game is like five and a
half hours so we might have some hey
dude I just realized look at this moon I
will I'm moonwalking I'm moonwalking in
this game now if you're not filled in on
the story don't worry I will explain it
all to you so please keep watching
please keep what damn it and he might be
Miss Lilly's place I'm joking
all the support on this has been amazing
okay well the story took a strange turn
last episode there's something going on
with dr. Watts
alright the we don't know what he's
doing but he's doing something there's
some other alternative adjustments to
this now I don't remember what I was
supposed to do do you hear me ever I'm
coming back in are you still in there
are you still there patients near links
to something like okay
oh my god thank you hey I think I saw
your partner smash interesting space me
spasming that's the word is something
wrong
of course not we got this down where we
I'm going back in there now
okay I'm catching on you I might as well
just go nothing holding me back now it's
very real
what do you guys think leave a comment
here they are again they're so cute
what I don't like this music though
where is she Peppa is it Abba or Eva in
Sweden is a yabba not that you care it's
probably best not to provoke anything
before figuring out what's going on I
should find Eva first ibanez Eva ha
don't need your help get out of here
where is she nanny
the [ __ ] she's in the post-office thing
of course but urine think Allah this is
strange very strange huh the link to his
timeline over whirl got unlocked
even if Eva's not there anymore it'd be
easier to look for her from there yeah
why not
I don't think she's here she's clearly
not here
what the heck Eridu carries this these
are all the mementos and all the links
we never seen this before
she's not here though Eva are you here
we became a flying sperm congratulations
everyone every memory of Colleen that we
pierced together so far she's gotta be
in one of them I actually have to find
her
oh not detected why could she be the
vortex of the anatomy that's been
bouncing its around
guess is near the memory we left off at
so I didn't read it not detected what is
happening to this game it's so different
now yeah not here either
she's not gonna be in any way either
she's here or not here she's missing
dagnabbit how can she be in the machine
but nowhere in the memories unless she's
here here system narrowed down
Eva's most recent position nanny well
duh freakin Bermuda Triangle
guess it's back to the crime scene
something's up
something's definitely a system load up
all available recordings from here this
video what is this to the moon tube I'm
heading out get ready get the forms
ready get the forms ready for a filling
wait what
all right fast-forward come on where is
she where is she freaking Court corn
cobs how can this one memory link be so
hard to find not it it sure is taking
his sweetie 9:36 p.m. wait a minute wait
a minute what she was to here fast
forward yes yes yes a few minutes later
are you at a computer so we don't know
what happened in between
good could you run this record search
and fan check for any aviation accidents
I just want to rule out the possibility
of something out okay all right a few a
few minutes later two minutes later and
she's got she's got there she is
Neil can you hear me hello are you there
Neil if you can hear me listen I don't
think she's real she's she's all in his
head
and something strange is happening hello
say something I'm giving up on you
goddamn this system glitched out this is
hella crazy whoa the tree just hey hey
but a bingo
what does happen oh well we've never
seen this before
what is this whoa oh oh that oh oh you
oh I'm scared for real what the heck
what you did it team oh my god
that was freaky as hell what damn it
visit him in the freaking genre beta
that setup birth oh my god this game
went from zero to 100 what do you want
love we can't leave this is our job
call in sign up cipher has to be here
the changes mom
belong here fine you want to play
hardball let's play freakin hit babe I
got a few trick are we gonna fight are
we gonna fight police fight
that's right are you gonna be nice now
you may have lost you have may have they
host subconsciousness but I'm still the
admin of this world melon I never
thought I'd have to use this but you
leave me no choice
it's 10:00 to show you my true power
oh this gesture control interface was a
terrible idea
[Music]
yeah Oh his transfer man uh
Salamone Kauai this name
well the minecraft armor the golden
minecraft armor the strongest armor of
all yay don't forget to helmet Wow
incredible
[Music]
this is so ridiculous this is what
happened whenever isn't around yeah Eva
Jesus if you think I'm going to show
mercy
you've been sadly mistaken give up now
and I make us ha ha ha old shoes she had
the last momento am she strong she took
it back
please leave
Oh dad maybe that's why this is so not
what I built that backdoor for I guess
even my code needs testing before
practical use and what the heck happened
to Eva I need to get to the bottom of
this oh now we're running the book I
can't really she was here wasn't she
when something happen what do I do
maybe you can go in here now any
instance of college should get me back
to the overworld so we're stuck here
okay
all right we're back with here system
narrow it down positions of rogue mental
activity what she's split up everywhere
where to even begin I'll get to that
when things aren't batch okay we just
have to look for her everywhere this is
so strange
she's here same way I find her dagnabbit
system disabled interactivity for all
non operators including Colin I find
that beer and I'll put her to justice
where we
where is she dammit I click that by
accident where should I go back I'll
just go back so clicking calling just
takes us back but we have to find her
somewhere shouldn't it be a no Mendte
the painting that is clicking on every I
don't know oh oh good good try but I
sure don't recall the person looking
like that you look a little distorted by
the way oh my god
so try scrilla Singh in there and look
in the Sun
[Music]
what what that but is this place
Laura tava know what wait a minute this
this is my unfinished interface how are
you even here
and where is Eva around I tell her you
were going to remove me from Connors
memories ah we weren't necessarily gonna
to do your job house or not you said
yourself that you'd start with me then
right you're right we only said that
because we didn't know you can hear us
ha ha ha wait wait that came out wrong
but listen you need to believe me I'm at
the patient side not the contract this
this just is a misunderstanding
Maria do what's best for Carling and you
can work with us to make it happen hmm
that does sound in person but the ribbon
as if that were the clothes but xalapa
loves her well that's no
[Music]
ow access to its current memory tonight
commencing first booty hey wait I'm the
admin ah [ __ ] damn it did my own system
just elope with my patients freaking
imaginary friend okay let's try another
one so she'll be hiding inside something
[Music]
this is the memory of him and his son oh
and we did see a shadow over here over
on this side that was you walking by
there wasn't it that's oh I think I just
twisted my voke of course that's none of
your business anymore
it's the same thing just gonna happen
over and over this again
Hey look over there oh I can't believe
that worked
I mean it didn't work but oh sorry I hit
space by accident why don't you just
give up and leave us alone
so now calling signed the contract but I
did it out of desperation but I only did
it and I didn't understand the
consequences for the dust now listen I
don't know what you take us for but
we're here to help him I mean I don't
know exactly how yet but at least give
us a chance
just tell me where eva is and I'll give
us the memory link so we can finish the
check your car look to tell you the
truth I don't actually nourishes and as
for the memory lunch
[Music]
I'm gonna [ __ ] slap it out of here
whoa okay girl half the girl formal I
said fight alright so I move and shoot
[Music]
that what's your choice but that's not
big I can't even leave a mark on you
whoa oh oh I can't block that what that
mean what was I supposed to do there
there was no chance at out how access to
current memory denied commencing first
booting okay this sex this is pretty
crazy
guess we just have no choice but to keep
keep doing this this is his last day
maybe we saw someone out here eyelashes
I found you so how did you buy a ticket
for that seat [ __ ] I wasn't even
here in the axle memory does it right
then who is she and where did she come
from
I am so confused Hey look that paper
plane thing was totally uncool but what
did you mean when you said you don't
know where eva is I saw the footage you
were the one who locked her away no all
I did was lock the communication
channels and give her scare I don't know
where she went afterwards in fact she
disappeared soon after you returned
disappeared as in she unplugged from the
machine plus she's no longer here and if
you don't love her well I'm gonna make
sure what is that was another one all
right what is it this time check wait
how are you even accessing my private
programs like this ow son of M that
wasn't what I was asking it out
and a hadoukens and [ __ ] jump defend
space well damn it I can't even Sheila
attacks Oh
aah I want to beat her
hey I was rooting for you I liked you a
minute ago alright what is this anymore
the diva really unplugged from the
machine
maybe I should to wait but if I'm not
here either they might even be able to
reset our progress I guess there's at
least some use in keeping her busy
alright we have two more this is fairly
straightforward
might as well I say oh wait a minute
shut the matter kudasai this this isn't
the last accessible memory where we
saved a communicative copy of Colin not
quite as bright as the real thing but
sharp eats nothing at uh
so where is she where is she I don't
what Oh Carlene can you hear me
oh this one in the front are your back
yes
listen I need your head god damn it what
the hell oh oh okay look at that
how did she get into the code you lock
down the one who created you that narrow
that's not the real Karla that's merely
a partial copy of him that were created
[Music]
look we don't have a lot of time Lee if
Carla's wishes to be fulfilled we need
you to work with us do you still not
understand Colin's register no longer
some something it's no longer something
you can grant to Katherine our it's
resolved to become what so what I didn't
do anything unless even ah hey that
wasn't so bad anymore wait a minute oh
sweet it's a Christmas miracle and it is
Christmas
don't tell the head of your stuff
uppercut punch
well it's about to get real guys this
again other words let's serve that song
[Music]
all right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay maybe I shouldn't okay I can block
some birds
[Music]
you're shocked man come on come on she's
presently taking any damage
[Music]
come on SDPs more dots more dots gather
Gacha sure time I can't dodge that this
is for calm only I have the power of God
and anime on my side I nearly found that
crazy all going oh oh no I uh
know what that one huh I'm alive Oh
Suzie Shh oh no it's getting hard
come on my head yeah I am the best gamer
in the planet whoa ow
rogue activity no longer detected in his
memory finally something's working this
is a vlog : still like some hair
returned to Colin's ever word yes we got
one more to go through
I wonder if it even matters if you beat
him Eva are you here some way she
clearly did something last time
oh this memory was so sweet we have to
ruin it
I liked your face you were the chosen
one you were supposed to bring balance
to the calling hey ha ha ha hey you've
been here since the beginning haven't
you love our love but supposed to live
alone
you're at the kick her ass again cuz I
will come on you lost your rage careful
not to cut it yourself on it that's
correct the confidence for someone who
just got lucky
there's still 10 work with this and
we'll make the best of this join us the
best of this word bizarre living Carlin
our Lara and I'll be the one method
shawl of that
I'm sorry Faye
you was going down oh I wasn't good at
this okay way down was defend you know I
can take you on now right ah Geronimo
[Music]
okay defend
our mother
[Music]
yeah it's not going great
no I was so close but I have to redo it
not freaking cool yeah I'll just redo it
I just messed up my bad haven't had
enough guess not
[Music]
leave calling along your crazy academic
what's with the jumping
[Music]
Wow
almost got her there you go easy best
camera on the planet thank you very much
I want to thank my mom
I want to thank swole Ben and I want to
thank anyone that is watching
do you like oh yeah Ava should see me
now what up Colin don't you learn how to
play a game like me all right
think about that external patching
installation initiated what that is that
you River rogue mental activity dig deep
this wasn't here before
suppose I can join him with my sperm
[Music]
here we are this is the breaking point
maybe even saud here she must be vicious
mmm
even their you why hey where have you
been I've been looking everywhere for
you
did you see pay around here don't worry
I took care of her excuse me I took care
of her
already what did you do oh and sorry
about the mess here I probably should
have cleaned it cleaned it up you know
I've been thinking that we should just
leave
wait what the patient clearly doesn't
want us here we should respect his
wishes
what are you talking about the patients
don't always know what they really want
do you of all people - now wait a minute
you know oh I guess it's nice you should
know by now you aren't just gonna leave
I really don't want to do anymore I
really don't know what to do anymore
but I have to keep going even if it just
turns you
[Music]
okay wait hold on just a minute
ah shoes what is going on this has been
so crazy
well this class sure aren't as fluffy as
they look disappointment uh-oh
it's boss battle time whoa I just became
an actual RPG huh
attack Armageddon kick wait there was
shoe as an option what can she do then
ow
well I have to try shoe yeah take that
ah nice in up up okay all right attack
tornado punch
yeah yeah look at everybody
ah ah ah she's too strong you know for
an imaginary character your attacks are
kind of vanilla ha ha yeah take shoo
ah shoot ah rudoug BrewDog he's on my
site ah nevermind ow ow and out in ow
yeah I could really use some help maybe
would defend one look we don't have to
do this then I'll never give up
dan look at that damage dawg
[Music]
but it's not enough I don't think we
could have won that one dagnabbit
wait what don't give up do you well
there was this one time with a long line
of at the grocery store but here guess
not
[Music]
do I just have to keep fighting guess I
have to learn which attacks do more
damage
[Music]
I do more damage nano may
I'm not sure what is expected of me here
[Music]
I'm still not strong enough shoe great
what that he put my shoe back rue
dawkins join the party ah
alright roadog compliment if nose laser
nose LASIK yeah hell yeah Rudolph ah son
of a road ugh this is now question
rudoug why true Doug the imaginary dog
is question and ceases exist dammit why
why yes my god this is ridiculous
[Applause]
never question your dog guys alright we
know that one does the most damage at
leas
[Music]
maybe we should just like not even
attack and just defend until we get ruh
dog I don't know probably that's what
you have to do I know I'll defend now
because now the dogs will come look at
that and then we'll throw the shoe ruh
dog returns just as planned
and then rude dog will do a rocket dog
[Music]
Dan Oh was that a chemically no he
wasn't good then hopefully we can
withstand at least two more attacks no
no no go back
oh come on don't question true dog
I'll just defend then okay cool and then
no lacing nice we can do this we can do
this yes defend go row dog as much as I
want to try the compliment it doesn't
seem worth it at this point we did it
amazing I am truly the greatest aren't
you glad you're watching I know you are
oh my where that was a hoot ah shoot Roo
Doc's still up there I forgot to thank
him but why did he help me shouldn't
y'all made-up beings act in unison of
Colin's subconsciousness maybe even
can't I mean save ISA no way so sherry
what'd he want
so wait it's the one widow that you
tempt him with it's not no surprise that
he got lost
hey Sookie do you mean it no what he
wants but they know what it needs
look you may be part of his mind but
clearly you don't speak for his entirety
could it be that you are wrong I mean no
offense but you aren't much more than
that in complete copy of Colin back
there in fact I'm not even sure if
there's a point in talking to you right
now after all you're just an authorial
figment of his imagination that never
even existed gonna hit you but they
start any different from what you're
here to do
[Music]
whoa we got all kinds of thing happening
Ava hey sorry I had to head out for a
moment there she's all in Colin's head
by the way oh yeah I'm intermediate
intimately familiar with that fact I
know but what were you doing you just
bail that on me
Oh Eva knows business
I was out administrating sturdiness to
curb Colin's brain activity not sure how
his mental process could override us but
it's getting out of hand
so that wasn't a Christmas miracle after
us it took a while to work out the dose
such as we still need his brain
functioning seems like it's working
though the effect should be sinking in
more now Oh not dog sport Wow just what
have you been dealing with over here
don't ask oh she got zapped a half
Batman what the heck is there just some
you cold Roxy sent me she said she saw
issues with the Machine earlier and knew
we'd be in trouble
wrote a patch in the car while Rob was
driving up early wow she's not showy
she's really not that dumb huh did did
she say anything else about the Machine
aside from you doing a crappy job with
the self repairs no not like there was
much time to talk actually I'm still not
sure I've Colin is stable enough for
this to work yet Oh
huh I didn't expect her to be locked
down for good this soon
did we just catch her as a pokemon
that's amazing you miss it
you missed a tire tired calling out
quite a bit
well there was a it was hard fun yeah
but whatever he was good thing this
worked my dad we'd have time Fred we
trying I don't I do have some questions
for you about this incident though but
those can wait until the case is done
The effect of this ladies is temporary
we have little time as it is
come on let's move on already what we
still came finally this might just be
the most hassle we've ever gone through
for a single memory link yep
seems about right hmm what is it oh it's
just something she said earlier hmm
the whole thing was messed up she did
she turned freaky and ghastly on YouTube
yeah but that's not what I meant
nevermind let's just get going in chat
later do we have what's the met meant oh
then I guess this is not exactly a
journal after all sheesh
are they just spreading hibiscus seeds
wherever they go there we go we got one
nice a memory link a memento oh it's
time finally for everyone's favorite 10
Oh No
oh there we go
and they don't stop coming and they
don't stop coming and they don't stop
coming and they don't stop coming I know
exactly what I'm doing
look at that genius strikes again oh my
god
let's go through Bros for a ChaCha's
squad famous what backing up interative
data for a plaid selection data Becker
complete Institute to repository
what in the world is Domino
that took a while
weren't you right behind me it just had
to clean up some some of them inspecting
and we never been here before have we
Wow let's go and see what we find out
there more takes of all this I have a
guess well here's another one of these
and wonder what's gonna happen I still
don't know maybe Faye is real I mean
she's gotta come from somewhere she
didn't eat a stick that there didn't
exactly stick this everything I'm sorry
didn't exactly see me landing her not
like I had much practice on an actual
grass strip
so do you think this is case of
schizophrenia well with that the patient
usually has trouble actively
distinguishing the Lucian's from reality
but I in this case I get the feeling
when he's that he's actually well aware
of it
still can't say for certain but I'm
leaning towards some kind of defense
mechanism instead the more curious
question is how she's able to
materialize so vividly you think she's
still able to you yes hard to say but
she shouldn't be able to interfere for
now at least this seems to be just a
normal memory playback
hmm interesting
would you forgive me haven't you ever
heard of the phrase stop and smell the
roses there are flowers in Tiffany Hill
tyranny reasoning they may kid she can't
just be in his head I don't believe that
I don't want to believe am
we're going a werewolf is hunting her
hey I was thinking it's a little windy
today maybe we should come back some
other time instead damn you
we're practically ready hey remember
when we played catch me she came the
wind it wasn't there a moment ago
so shit's getting windy okay what did
you marry me
let's just rest here for a while begin
your braid avoid Timmy steeps
hey I'm the one who has to carry this
thing up here oh I just said you dad
couldn't throwing up I knew that soon
the cello got bigger to you now look
just come and sit here with me for a bit
will you
do you remember the first time we came
here Reese Fritzi
the second time I or the second one I
guess the one where I tried to race you
up to her
oh you did with a damn moon she really
said it to take me up there though yeah
it had been a while since I took anyone
there it's still one of my favorite
places
I've always liked how it overlooked the
city it really has been a while hasn't
it
I rather miss going there will mean it
seeps away from their union why are you
stopping every step along the way
stop kidding yourself Kelly you're not
tired and it's not the wind
we've already came so far you know well
is it as I what we have to do what
sorry what
why is it so quiet
are they playing
where are they there
[Music]
the first time we came here that was the
first time I accompanied you to play
this game stay with me yeah it helped
it's still dust actually we do we like
to practice even noon but you can never
actually hear whether it was playing
kick you why what
[Music]
oh it's nice up here today we turn with
this you don't have to leave anymore
I can fly now wherever you go I can go
with you
you really is definitely don't you think
you're getting a bit too old for me to
stay people would love for you if they
knew they can laugh all they want I
don't care you made me who I am today
I learned to fly because of you I kept
playing the cello because of you you
taught me to practice the scales okay I
can't teach you anything you don't know
nor can I make you do anything you don't
want maybe all you really wanted was for
something to be there even if it was
this someone like me
who is she I know it's mesmerizing here
Connie but you've been spending so much
time with me and I'm and imagining what
couldn't be don't you think you're
forgetting what actually is and all that
could be sometimes stepping out this
little world we may be it's the only way
to notice and appreciate all the
beautiful things around you I just don't
want to be alone sure if I go you'll be
alone attempts even when you don't want
to be but that's not a part of growing
up and it's all part of life it's what
makes fleeting moments with our
inspiration
in our memories pictures
it's also a tragedy to seek out what you
wouldn't find if you just stayed here
with me there's a lady right there just
waiting for you I'm sorry the voice I
hate it right now I can't promise it or
let me speak it but I know you won't
find out that you need living only these
pages emerged he brought me into this
world
don't forget II in my thinking same
entity same I only meant to carry
yourself oh he made me I know you know I
will always be there to protect you and
whatever comes if it's something we
could do then it's something you could
do what do you say curling are you ready
I'm not
I don't know
I don't think I'm ready for it to him I
don't care what you are or aren't you
weren't my first real friend
hey this isn't have to infer it one day
you may look back and realize her face
this precious life has passed you by and
on that day you come back once more I'll
come back once more we'll talk like how
we used to talk and you tell me about
your day
know about your life you tell me about
what a happy life you had I know the
nice memories you've had I might not
have such a happy life you know oh I get
it now you're sick it's a dannion you
know then have another faith in you save
carolling of course you will I know you
will
it may take a long time and it may take
a lot of work and effort but we met a
chance I know you'll have lots of happy
memories she
a thought mistake how much have you
written in that but by now every place
it's made you so many times I must talk
a lot sorry by day but I'm killing
perhaps you could finally spend more a
page for other things it's your book you
don't know I have to always write about
me anymore
it's just like life right same book
forever there were kinds of different
pages and they should be
take care of you tampering hey I still
haven't said goodbye
[Music]
long long time ago
why sorry can I just finish she never
came back did she guess not
and when if she's a connoisseur in
effect mm-hmm Rosie do you think Colin's
unhappy because she never came back
again if Colin only wanted to see her
again
adapt she would have needed to call us
he would have needed Scott yeah but
perhaps your insanity and meant that she
was already unhappy he was already
unhappy by then back to square one this
place is dis table anything again we
don't have much time left let's move we
have to make do with what we had
wait do we even know what we're doing
with him yet a few ideas to try but
still need to link to momenta first
let's get back to the overworld and
figure things out what we do that all
right
uh-oh what the heck
wait Chester
in my own way I will always be there to
protect you
yeah what's taking so no [ __ ] oh this
place is [ __ ] up I there's no tank to
wait for him okay let me do a quick same
we're gonna have to end that episode
there excuse me I've only been away a
few minutes I was like I wonder if it's
actually that much left so I looked up
and I didn't know what's gonna happen or
anything but I looked up just to be safe
and it's true I I literally have we have
like 20 minutes left and it would be
insane to stop now even though this
episode will be super extra long which I
know you of course appreciate oh okay we
need to connect the links the book to
the book the plane to the plane and the
Hibiscus to the Hibiscus he doesn't have
any hibiscus so that's not gonna work
okay he's the only I think this is it
yeah the Hibiscus was the key all along
I am good at this aren't I
maybe I probably just sold the puzzles
so much quicker than everyone else and
that's why I thought the play time was
different but I'm probably just such a
genius that I can't have my set
it's late all right I'm saying overtime
I think that's a little bit oh my god oh
my god oh hell yeah
[Music]
I just realized I shouldn't have read
fades voice in such a stupid [ __ ]
moist such a such an emotional moment
I'm just doing this stupid voice what is
this place Hey look at that
so I guess Fay was like his fake friend
like a pretend friend I don't know what
it's called in English
excuse me call them call them but when
you go through the procedure and live
that new life just hold on to something
from here it's not like that for you I
won't forget about you damn it I guess
he's dying
but in the blink of an eye suddenly
there's no more time and I find myself
here just like everyone else I just want
to feel like I've done enough in this
world before I go you know that's why we
are here calling tell us your regrets
what is it you want us to fix
we only have so little time in this
knife and we'd never be able to do all
that we want no matter what we do
there'd always be other things we'd want
to try other paths to take
uh-huh
did I spell it on your address
hey just one more excuse to jump into
the lagoon you know we don't have to
waste all that lemon juice have you ever
tried riding with it
lemon juice no why ha then prepared to
be mind blown by some elementary school
magic get this it's invisible ink
invisible ink
yep writing appears in color only when
you heat the paper up come on I'll show
you let's write something with it it's
been a while since I written
it was Fay was like a fictional
character for him it's never too late to
start again how about a letter to her
each other of course we write about this
trip
it's been kind of a journey has an a and
at the end of it we could show each
other whoa we wrote of it all
hmmm why was this not part of the memory
earlier
why would you even consider why would
you toss aside everything we had for
something make-believe
I'm not tossing anything aside
we all have regrets Pia driving or a
wrong or dream long past a dream land
past a Sigmund Court we give you that
second chance to make things right
because with our help it's never too
late
wait these don't seem to seem like just
randomly scattered memories could it be
that the sedated sweating wearing off
you are different even from the man you
were when I first met you you're no
longer aloof you know when you're here
you're actually here
I know it's mesmerizing here Facebook
after a pause shifting her gaze back up
to the sky but you've been spending so
much time with me and imagining what
couldn't be don't you think you're
forgetting what actually is and all that
could be
okay look I got it I got your message
you hear me I know you're still here you
can come and get me now
what damn it I really thought it was her
uh wait is that really the only way yeah
where the heck have you been
I figured it out Eva I figured out the
impossible I mean I took an unholy
amount of spoon it took an unholy amount
of spoon fitting but I guess that's what
it takes when you're on the inside of it
what are you talking about yes just what
are you talking about
the Cydia team if we're off already you
don't sound too happy about it we're
here we're here to help Colin and you're
the mental process that's in the way
well lucky for you that can be a men now
can't it so looks like we're about out
of time if you're going to raise me for
good you might as well hurry no we're
not going to no we're not going to erase
you we're going to erase us wait what
Colin never needed our service Eva he
already had her the ability to change
his reality to live in a different world
one that filled the gash but what he
wanted all in his head she is what we do
even and yet she lent she left which
which could have only meant one thing
what are you trying to imply no that
can't be right
what we do is different from just this
how is this different because there's
more to it there's more to what we do we
fulfill wishes we give meaning to
people's lives what we do it has to be
more than just an imaginary friend it's
a lot more elaborate for sure but for
someone who had to fight just to let go
of a fantasy and embrace reality so I
can't read
maybe our existence were Marilee and
welcome to haplin
our reminder of the maker belief the
imaginary and the endless possibility
that make reality seem less than what it
is
hey you two things are looking good with
the patient I don't know what you're up
to but you might want to get out of
there and by might wanna I mean need to
after all that huh I guess none of this
even matters anymore there's no way we'd
still have to the time to implement any
actual changes no we might not have the
10 but what about her she started linked
to the machines interface right without
us all the procedures would be
internalized so much could be done in a
fraction of a moment you'd suggest in
giving sole control of the machine to a
mental process of the patient the
ethical implications of that it hasn't
been done for good reason it hasn't been
done because no patient had the Hatters
has had a chance like this
besides what's eternity just leaving
mark this as a rata but what about widow
complications in the contract it says oh
come on even when it's a contract stop
test
guys go by I'll be right behind don't
say you need to trust you
why are you doing this for us
well if I were calling and on my last
breath I trust you our two strangers in
white coats right
strangers huh your colleague was right
about one thing
there is more to what you do than just
playing God with people's memories
you've been here for just a day yet in
all his lifetime
no one has truly seen the world through
his eyes like you have and well you're
kind of the first I've been able to meet
to in some silly way maybe that's a part
of what Colleen really wished for it was
one heck of a meet-and-greet that's for
sure full admin access granted to
unknown faith
you're gonna be alright just a little
nervous against well given the
circumstances I'd say that's pretty high
ring hey judgeth don't you think that in
some ways I've truly existed well for
what it's worth I think all our memories
and everything in it can be nothing but
the fiction we tells our stuff
good luck out there
Carl is counting on you I mean how is
she any different from what they were
gonna do in his head right
his blood pressure is dropping vital
signs are fading fast I think is letting
go
goodbye calling
I'm sorry for your loss please take all
the time you need
I'll be in their living room with the
paperwork when they're ready I'll let
them know
I can't do the voices now
dr. Watts always a little stark isn't he
seeing it like this after just having
been in there
yeah and it's what it is I'm just a
little cold
if it felt warm in here
what you did back there do you think do
you know if it were hard to say I try to
dig through the data afterwards but well
it's never been done like this before
I don't know how coherent you'll be
guess we got another mess of a report to
write we can take care of that when the
dust settles in the meantime I just
remember something
so did you succeed
there was a complication
we try to cope with something unorthodox
but I'm not sure if we'll ever know what
really happened in those nice moments
hey Sophie I said you got a lighter uh
yeah
oh of course he brought it in lemon
juice
I never stood up very tall
my voice was fairly small but there were
times I'd wanna shout though my thoughts
weren't sorted out so I'd stumble and
I'd fall
because of you
so if you left I could go to
and everything you saw me that's what I
wanted to be did I make it after all Oh
Fras on the third
is it only greater in my mind I'd still
want it full same because training my
yesterday
is to wish my life away
as we dream men as we grow we have to
learn to let these go but let the wander
never fade though we've turned ten
thousand pages flying higher stop
I search for meaning I'll instead
I finally figured that out
and all the stories inside me feels like
I'm bursting at the seams and you're
here after all
all the grass on
only great
I'd still wanted the same because
training my yesterday
is to wish my life away
Oh
[Music]
looking for something old-timer it's
been a while huh
you haven't changed much it as far as
that now
[Music]
Jesus Christ
I got a coal or something
can you son-of-a-bitch
damn it yeah hit me I don't know where
oh my god
[Music]
this funeral
yeah
[Music]
now very worthy is looking sketchy at
all not looking sketchy eye on you I
asked you to knock not hack my lock
switching to digital was a terrible idea
why don't you just keep both locks on
dag NAB a trap I don't know why she even
got you in vote look we don't have long
are you guys still in or night
you betcha so it's this this solution
you were talking about yeah that's right
what
episode 2 finding paradise check Oh
the story continues huh oh my god thank
you for being part of it thank you for
making it god damn it
all right oh there we go I'm back I
wasn't ready for it
[Music]
okay I'm keep writing reviews and
everyone's like oh just know just get us
to the moon I didn't even cry I'm like
okay well I didn't cry really doing to
the moon so I doubt this will hit me and
then Jesus Christ a feeling the feels
train just hit me
I wasn't ready at all I don't know why I
I think I was less mature back then I
know that sounds like a [ __ ]
hypocrite thing to say it with all the
voices and [ __ ] I did but I remember I
enjoyed to the moon a lot but I don't
know if I it had such an emotional
impact on me like the second one bed and
I can only explain it for that but holy
cow I'm really good I play this I'm
really glad I finished that regardless
of
what Beus were or whatever this is such
an amazing experience and I'm really
glad I got to share it with you guys
please support this game buy it on Steam
if you enjoyed it
even if you watch me playing I think
that that seems pretty fair and yeah I
don't know
thanks to can again and thanks everyone
for watching I'm gonna go and pretend
this last 10 minutes never happens
because broth
[Music]